[Music]
what drove sofia bush and chad michael
murray apart after they fell in love on
the set of one tree hill which classic
sitcom star celebrated her on-screen
husband's death with a round of
champagne keep watching and all will be
revealed
before he was known as that guy who
starred in all those religious films
kirk cameron broke big as mike seiver on
the abc sitcom growing pains alas when
he converted to christianity near the
end of the show's run he became a holy
terror there are differing accounts of
what exactly went down between cameron
and his co-star julie mcauliffe who
played julie costello but it's clear
that neither one liked the other very
much there are two different versions of
the story though everyone besides
cameron tells the same one in a 2017
interview with wingman magazine
mcauliffe claimed that cameron had her
removed from the show because she'd
posed nude in playboy which went against
his newfound faith he gave her an
ultimatum and that proved to be the end
of a run cameron has never spoken
publicly about the incident but he was
quite controlling on the set which he
admitted to in an interview with cbn at
times he even forced writers to rewrite
scenes that he deemed immoral when you
make a decision like i'm not comfortable
saying that line or doing that scene
well that meant that 11 writers had to
come up with a new scene
furthermore he confessed to the los
angeles times in 2000 that he cut off
contact with his growing pain's cast
mates for quite some time so it's not
too hard to believe that he used his
clout to kick someone off the show as
for mcauliffe her twitter feed makes it
quite clear that she's still not a fan
of her former co-star she called him out
in 2017 for his words about the victims
of hurricane irma
ross and rachel were the couple on
friends that everyone couldn't stop
talking about but when they were on one
of their famous breaks rachel tried to
seduce joshua played by tate donovan the
two eventually had a brief relationship
but joshua's arc is mostly remembered
for the incredibly cringe-worthy ways in
which jennifer aniston as rachel tried
to seduce him the writing made it
uncomfortable but there was another
factor at play behind the scenes that
made the relationship even more awkward
aniston and donovan had been a couple in
real life and they'd just broken up when
he got the call to appear on friends he
thought this might be a healthy way to
move past the relationship but he soon
discovered that the opposite was true in
a 2013 interview with huffpost live he
admitted that filming romantic scenes
with his ex was horrible while also
noting i remember just getting back to
my dressing room and just weeping
donovan may have been able to laugh
about it while looking back but it was
clearly a bad experience for him at the
time
charlie sheen isn't exactly known for an
even tempered demeanor he was famously
fired from two and a half men in 2011
following a series of bizarre comments
and behavior and he quickly made enemies
on his follow-up show as well fx decided
that they could make some money with the
sitcom starring sheen so they hired him
for the aptly named anger management
working alongside sheen was selma blair
who played his therapist and part-time
lover kate alas sheen immediately got up
to his old antics including showing up
late and being unprofessional on set
when blair brought the issue up jean
turned on her as one insider told e he
went full throttle into getting her off
the show immediately unsurprisingly for
a charlie sheen vehicle the environment
on set was described as awkward and
toxic for everyone the real kicker was
that blair reportedly found out that she
was fired via text message
sometimes co-stars hit it off right away
only for the relationship to gradually
deteriorate over time but fortunately
nina dobrev and paul wesley experienced
the complete opposite when they starred
together on the vampire diaries dobrev
played elena who was in a love triangle
with paul wesley's stefan and ian
somerhalder's daemon alas dobrev and
wesley clashed immediately they both
stayed quiet about it at the time but
they've talked about it in the years
since during a 2019 appearance on the
directionally challenged podcast for
example dobrev explained there's a fine
line between love and hate and we
despised each other so much that it read
as love
wesley seconded these thoughts in an
interview with entertainment tonight as
he admitted
creatively it just wasn't in sync
thankfully this story has a happy ending
the timeline of the reconciliation is a
little wonky as dobrev says it only took
a few months while wesley claims it took
a few seasons but regardless they
eventually became friends they only have
praise for each other now with both
saying that they talk regularly so now i
just adore her she adores me
pretty much any fan of the x-files knows
that despite mulder and scully's
crackling chemistry on screen the actors
who played them didn't get along
off-screen david duchovny and jillian
anderson played the famous fbi agents on
the fox drama and their characters
eventually went from professional
partners to romantic pair to the delight
of legions of viewers however working
that closely with one other person for
years can lead to some struggles which
duchovny talked about in a 2008
interview with metro at that point he
was able to look back fondly on his time
on the show and even compared anderson
to his sister however he also said that
familiarity breeds contempt and the two
simply got sick of working together
though he insisted that it had nothing
to do with her specifically the intense
shooting schedule and serious subject
matter led to petty arguments and the
company explained that it got to the
point that he and anderson quote
couldn't stand the sight of each other
thankfully this is another story with a
happy ending as the two reunited for an
x-files reboots in 2016 and they'd
clearly gotten past any animosity
particularly if their interview on jimmy
kimmel live from that year is anything
to go by these are people that get along
these two people that i'm looking at
right here
go on
before there was ross and rachel or
mulder and scully tv's ultimate will
they or won't they couple was maddie and
david on moonlighting who were played by
sybil shepard and bruce willis
respectively fans tuned in every week to
see them solve cases and flirt with each
other unfortunately like so many tv
couples with unresolved romantic tension
things quickly went downhill after they
resolved it in 2005 shepard told
entertainment weekly that willis was
great to work with at first as she put
it with bruce the temperature in the
room went 20 degrees higher for me
anyway
however over time the two of them simply
began to hate each other she blamed the
mutual dislike on the show's volatile
nature but their co-star curtis
armstrong has claimed that there was
more to the story as he wrote in his
book revenge of the nerd bruce intimated
to me that there had been one
disastrously ill-conceived thing between
him and sybil early on in the show's run
while not going into explicit details he
made it clear that that kind of mistake
was one i should be sure never to make
fortunately though willis and shepard
eventually decided that their grudge
should die hard with the vengeance and
they even reunited at his comedy central
roast in 2018.
acting alongside someone you've recently
broken up with is one thing but acting
alongside your ex-husband who cheated on
you is another entirely alas that's
exactly what sophia bush had to do on
the teen drama one tree hill she played
brook davis who was in a love triangle
that also involved chad michael murray's
lucas scott at first the romantic
tension between the two boiled over
happily into real life as bush and
murray quickly got engaged and married
but it all came crashing down almost
immediately
the couple said i do in april 2005 but
then they split up in september of that
same year on a 2006 episode of ryan
seacrest's radio show musician nick
carter alleged that this was because his
ex-girlfriend paris hilton had an affair
with murray unfortunately for murray and
bush they had to continue working on one
tree hill together until it came to an
end in 2012. bush has since tried to
avoid talking about the incident but
when it did come up during a 2021
episode of the inside of you podcast she
explained i'm not going to talk about
him i'm not allowed to because i've
tried to poke fun at being a dumb kid
and whenever i've done that it gets
twisted it's not worth my time it's not
a place where i harbor ill will or
anything
similar to mulder and scully richard
castle and kate beckett were
professional partners who also had
fantastic romantic chemistry the castle
leeds eventually became a couple and
started a family as the seasons went on
but the relationship between actors
nathan fillion and stoner katic was
apparently not quite as rosy neither
actor has publicly addressed a working
relationship directly but an insider
told us weekly in 2016 that things were
indeed quite difficult on set phillian
was reportedly so harsh to catic that
she would cry in her dressing room and
the two were apparently even forced to
attend counseling sessions together the
show ended in 2016 after eight seasons
but her departure from it was quite
messy first it was announced that her
contract hadn't been renewed and then
abc announced that the show was ending
in a 2018 interview with entertainment
weekly katic addressed her departure by
noting it hurt and it was a harsh ending
however she did also claim that she was
still overall thankful for the
experience
sitcoms wouldn't be what they are today
without i love lucy lucille ball was of
course the star of the show but her
co-stars vivian vance and william
frawley who played lucy's neighbors
ethel and fred mertz were also a big
part of what made it so great the always
bickering couple had fantastic chemistry
but the fighting didn't end when the
camera stopped rolling
vance was only two years younger than
ball but she was playing the wife of a
man more than two decades her senior
according to the book meet the mertes
fans admitted i loathed william frawley
and the feeling was mutual whenever i
received a new script i raced through it
praying that there wouldn't be a scene
where we had to be in bed together
frawley in turn didn't have very nice
things to say as he quipped she's one of
the finest girls to come out of kansas
but i often wish she'd go back there
according to an oft-repeated story which
was recorded in the book the dead
celebrity cookbook vance was at a
restaurant when she learned that frawley
had died upon hearing the news she
ordered champagne for everyone whether
or not this story is true it accurately
sums up the hostile working relationship
between the two
martin lawrence is no stranger to
controversy his infamous saturday night
live monologue in 1994 reportedly got
him a lifetime ban from the show for
example his sitcom martin which ran on
fox from 1992 to 1997 was popular but
also not without controversy a big
reason for the show's success was
lawrence's chemistry with tasha campbell
who played his wife gina alas things
were much rockier when the cameras
weren't rolling campbell left the show
in the fifth season and brought legal
action against lawrence for repeated and
escalating sexual harassment sexual
battery verbal abuse and related threats
the case was ultimately settled out of
court and campbell returned for the
show's finale however since lawrence
wasn't allowed to be around her when she
shot her scenes it made for an awkward
conclusion in the 2020 interview with gq
lawrence claimed that the sexual
harassment quote didn't happen meanwhile
campbell revealed on an episode of the
talk that same year that due to the
settlement agreement she isn't allowed
to speak about the matter in much detail
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abused and
incest national network website or
contact reigns national helpline at
1-800-656-hope 1-800-656-4673
[Music]
you